let's go back to the phone lines and
hear from a few more people you can join
the discussion at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to raj from ontario raj
welcome
hi david um i hope you're doing well uh
can you hear me well i can hear you fine
raj
okay i just wanted to first say thank
you for taking my call as well as for
holding a town hall especially this part
too to get everyone please also congrats
on your newborn i just heard about that
yesterday as well thank you um no
problem and uh my only question is uh
and i understand you're very busy but um
would you ever consider
um having an interview with canadian
author stephen marsh on the current
political situation in the u.s and
that's all i'll let you answer and uh
please stay safe and take care all right
i've never heard of the person i'm
always willing to have interviews with
people that are interesting but i would
have to research
um the person and uh i wouldn't rule it
out is that fair
yeah absolutely absolutely i will soon
be in canada so i'm going to be
undertaking my own investigation as to
who i should be interviewing if that's
fair
wow okay yeah i hope your i hope your
journey to canada is uh you know is a
smooth one and i hope you enjoy your
stay as much as you can yeah i'm gonna
try not to get stuck at the border you
know these things can get very very
crazy with the canadian border patrol i
i'm worried they will not like my
political activity and may not let me in
uh just a word of advice if you can
avoid pearson international airport
that's a big bonus because that's the
biggest one and uh you know delays are
usually going to happen there but i you
know i don't think you'll have a any
issues coming oh no i'll be driving in
i'll be going up 87 so it should be i
mean you know you can get a line the
cars start cueing up you know
okay excellent then yeah i'm sure we'll
have a knife nice drive up here and
there's electric vehicle chargers in
canada
oh
our infrastructure's a little lacking
but like along the 401 and like you know
in metropolitan areas you won't have any
problem okay all right i don't want to
get stuck there that'd be humiliating
it wouldn't be humiliating you know
things happen all the time everyone
makes projects okay don't don't worry
about it do you i'm sure you'll you'll
find a way all right raj thank you for
the call
no problem thank you very much david and
take care all right you too very
important considerations there maybe i
should just rent a gas powered car i
don't know
all right let's go next to chris from
massachusetts chris welcome
uh chris is one of our moderators who
unmutes themselves regularly chris
welcome
thanks for having me pleasure i wanted
to ask um
do you do any like uh
you know outdoor sporting activities
like fishing or anything like that you
know i've nev yes hiking yes i have
never done i recently actually did some
beautiful hiking in the
hudson
new york area which is quite
an interesting area for hiking um i
fishing i don't do it here's the thing
about fishing it seems so boring so so
so boring and i get it's like a sort of
zen thing and you're out there on the
water and whatever it just really seems
boring to me
um
i mean i would disagree maybe uh because
you're not catching anything
well i don't know that i'm not catching
or not i'm just not fishing you know
the reason i ask is i just wanted to
kind of take this opportunity to uh
proselytize a little bit about
conservation uh right now there's a bill
uh called the return act that was
introduced by
um a republican and back has about 50 or
so republican co-sponsors it's the
return act and what it does is it seeks
to repeal
the pittman-robertson act uh in the
dingle-johnson act um
acts from the early
20th century that put
a 10 to 11 excise tax on all
uh firearms uh ammunition
uh hunting fishing equipment
and the revenue from
this from these two bills
in some states makes up
about uh 60
of all of the conservation funding okay
um
for
you know maintaining state parks
uh maintaining uh public waterways
um
and uh
i think that because of how much funding
for conservation comes from like the
sporting and the outdoors uh
the the sporting part of of the outdoors
uh community yeah um we on the left
really need to think of like some
creative ways to
you know continue to fund conservation
one of the proposals that has been
fought against by the outdoor industry
um you know is a what people call a
backpack tax
this would be a similar excise tax one
to three percent on other recreational
uh
you know goods like boots dirt bikes
backpacks
uh outdoor apparel
and um you know as somebody on the left
who is part of like who is a hunter and
an angler you know i get a lot of kind
of pushback from like you know people of
the left to have a distaste for
you know hunting and fishing which is
fine
um but
we can't
seed the conservation effort
to the republicans because they are
going to
continue just like every other you know
aspect of uh you know government
government funding they're going to try
to
undermine it abolish it and privatize it
that's right
without a doubt that's what they will
try to do chris i love the declaration
incredibly powerful did you have a
question for me
did i have a well the first question i
asked you was you know are you in the
outdoor are are you involved in uh
outdoor uh sporting activities
but i uh then i i used my opportunity to
you know maybe encourage people to
you know get out and start fishing i
guess all right well that is a uh an
activity among many which i encourage
the audience to consider
thank you david all right chris from
massachusetts with a number of different
items
on the agenda let's go next to yoink
from the philippines yoink welcome
can you hear me well yes i can
oh hi
uh i'm only using an earphone mic so i
think uh i think my audio is going to be
a little bit messed up for me from your
part well let's do what we can doing
welcome
ah hello hello hello
um so uh i don't really have a
particular question in mind but i'm sure
you've heard
uh that
we have a new president yes a very
controversial one indeed yes
yeah indeed very much so
actually i was
a member here for a long time let's say
like
last year and i was just kind of
educating people and what they really
want to know and what they want to ask
anything about the philippines
and so do you have anything to ask me
well do you have any
city or in a more rural part of the
philippines
i live in a city you live in a city okay
i live in yeah
so is life in a city in the philippines
i don't know how much you've tr have you
traveled for example to western europe
or the united states
i did travel to the united states once
but how do you think that life differs
how does life differ in a city in the
philippines in your opinion from life in
the united states
um
i wouldn't really call like the life
that i had because i was only there for
like a couple weeks but i could say that
i could say that it's much slower in the
united states whereas in here
well i i wouldn't really say slower
because i've been in california and i
think new york is way faster but in
in in like in california it's like
it's kind of down
it's
turned down a bit like in when it comes
to pace but when it comes to like here
in the philippines especially when
you're like in the like mains like not
really the main streets but in like the
depths of the city you can really feel
like the speed and the things of the
things that are going on there so yeah
um
how would you is what's the relationship
like with the police where you are is it
generally speaking people have a
trusting relationship with the police
like i'll give you an example in
argentina for a very long period of time
like if you were going to be away for
two weeks you wouldn't let the police
know so that they would watch your place
because you would be worried the police
would break into your place whereas in
many places in the united states if
you're going to be away for a couple
weeks you call the police and they can
you guys keep an eye on my house because
i'm not going to be here what's the
relationship like with the police where
you are
yeah it has a little bit of like a
trusting effect because um especially
during the like the rodrigo rover
duterte's uh time yeah when he was still
the president especially at that time
people didn't trust them and now at
least um at least until
at least now this time
there's a little bit of a trusting
effect um especially when like oh okay
it's a new guy so maybe he will like
it's not that it's officiated that the
drug war has ended like the hardly
controversial drug wars ended yeah but
it seems that you know it's not reported
as much anymore like
like i don't really hear anything
anymore like killings and stuff like
that i mean do you hear any more of
killings i mean i don't so killings from
the in the philippines you mean
yeah yeah yeah of the no i guess i'm not
i can't say i'm following it necessarily
that closely but uh very interesting
yeah
but because what i heard from that is
that there was a very controversial like
killing that even reached the the united
states it was like a student who was
just dragged out by a drunk police
officer then he was killed like in front
of a cctv camera and then the cctv
camera captured like
um the police putting
a bag of meth or i don't know it's just
it's called it's i think it's cocaine
yeah i didn't see that one new york i
didn't see that one you want but i i
very much appreciate the phone call
thank you
yeah yeah thanks thanks thank you from
the philippines hope to hear from you
again